I got the
obviously going over to with Garden
number so I like if you clean going
through excited
and it's still only if I was just to
back into a really bad sickness bug
but she would have been lethargic a bit
lethargic and like he would
so then I got the little girl on my mom
come and picks us up and whenever she
come and she could she took me to walk
in hospital
and they went in to see her
and she didn't look too bad and I
thought oh actually I had to have given
her some fluids and stuff like that
so my mom left with my little daughter
Florence she went home
so me and me and care were watching them
got the iPad out
and then she just went into total she
was completely changed I couldn't get
Restless
they showed some more nurses down
and then we just had to leave the room
to just put it to sleep and she'd been
on events later ever since keeping her
alive
and um
yeah he's just been on a ventilator
keeping alive and
it's just the worst it's the worst thing
that's ever can ever happen to anybody